we're asked to graph y is equal to 2.5
times x so we really just have to think
about two points that satisfy this
equation here and the most obvious one
is what happens when x equals zero when
x equals zero 2.5 times zero is going to
be zero so when x is zero
y is going to be equal to 0.
and then let's just pick another x that
will give us a
a y that is a whole number so if x
increases by 1 y is going to increase by
2.5 it's going to go right over there
and i could graph it just like that and
we see just by just by what i just said
that the unit rate of change of y with
respect to x is 2.5 a unit increase in x
a one an increase of one in x results in
a 2.5 increase in y you see that right
over here x goes from 0 to 1 y goes from
0 to 2.5 but let's increase x by another
one and then y is going to increase by
2.5 again to get to 5. or you could say
hey look if x is equal to 2 2.5 times 2
is equal to 5. so this is a legitimate
graph for this equation but then they
also tell us to select the the
statements that are true
so the first one is the equation does
not represent a proportional
relationship well this is a proportional
relationship a proportional relationship
is one where first of all if you have
zero x's you're going to have zero y's
where y is equal to some constant times
x and here y is equal to 2.5 times x so
this is definitely a proportional
relationship so i'm not going to check
that
the unit rate of the relationship is
two-fifths so i'm assuming this is a
little ambiguous the way that stated it
i'm assuming they're saying the unit
rate of change of y with respect to x
and the unit rate of change of y with
respect to x is when x increases 1 y
changed
2.5
so here they're saying when x changes by
1 y changes by 0.4 two-fifths is the
same thing as point four it should be
this should be five halves five halves
would be two point four so this isn't
right as well
the slope of the line is two point five
well this looks right slope is change in
y over change in x when x changes 1 y
changes 2.5 so change in y 2.5 over
change in x 1 2.5 over 1 is 2.5 and you
could also see it looking at the form of
this equation y is equal to this is the
slope times x so that's right
a change of five units in x results in a
change of two units in y
well let's let's test that idea we know
when x is zero y is zero so if x goes
from zero to five what's going to happen
to y
well y is going to be 2.5 times 5 which
is 2.5 times 5 is
12.5 so y would not just change 2 it
actually would change 12.5 so this isn't
right
a change in of two units in x results in
a change of five units in y well we see
that a change in two units of x results
in a change of five units in y that's
exactly what we graphed right over here
these two points show that
so this is definitely true